uh talk about uh obviously this record
with Bryson is dope um shout out to
Bryson who doesn't do many features no
he doesn't do a lot so it it's got to be
you know dope to be able to kind of like
get a he's he's one of them guys you
know what I'm saying yeah Bryson just
was telling me like hey I rock with your
movement I think you're a do dope artist
and and he he did what he could do he
did what he do like he always do he
don't miss and I'm grateful to have that
because I know when Bryson pop out it's
a reason for Bryson to pop out for sure
he's like an introvert for like big time
yeah like he just I think he's just more
focused on music more than anything yeah
like it's not even a it's not it's he
don't focus a lot of people a lot of
artists focus on a lifestyle as well but
with him I feel like he just focused on
the music more than anything yeah thing
um being from Brooklyn do are you are
you like a ncks or a Nets person or do
you not give a [__] don't put me in that
don't I'm I'm you want get back from
both you want to do half time at both
teams right don't do me like that man
but
listen shout out to the [__] shout out
they're both really abusive
relationships as fans I'm sure listen
I'm I'm I know the N is it's new right
they from New Jersey yeah okay well then
it is what it is don't put me in a
sports thing I don't know I don't I
don't
know so don't I'm not about to sit here
and be lying to y'all I just like to
watch the game I don't care what game it
is I just have you been to more Nets or
Nicks games I've been to more Liberty
games honestly shout out to the Liberty
shout out to the Liberties they just
went to the finals yeah get me but we
did you go I didn't I couldn't I
couldn't make it I wanted to go don't do
you remember when Rebecca Lobo was on
the Liberty do are you I don't think
you're no I'm not I'm not like all the
way I just started tapping into when the
WNBA started they had this giant white
woman on the Liberty her name was
Rebecca Lobo she played for the
Connecticut uh Huskies she was just this
Giant mountain of a white lady she was
really good at basketball she was good
yeah how much she was doing on on a game
what points you was putting up I can't I
I'm I'm not going to lie a you don't
know that far huh female basketball's
gotten a lot better recently it's no
it's gotten like really good when I grew
up it was like we had like Cheryl swoops
Lisa Leslie Lobo listen I love there was
like there was a part you know maybe 10
years ago it was just hard to watch but
now like you know the lities is doing
shout out to the Liberties those my
girls Laney you heard have you performed
at a game yet like any I I try to I I
try to do what I could do I did Liberty
I did next game I did I think I did the
next twice so you're a Nets fan [__] the
Knicks I'm kidding I'm kidding they
ain't had you perform [__] them we we
rocking with the Nets they had you
perform twice come on man Mel Bridges is
over there that's a for shout out to the
NS they take care of I really love they
really do take care of me all the time
shout out to them and they just gave me
a gift not too long ago thank you what
they give you I can't tell you what what
gift could a basketball team give you
that you can't talk about because it's
only it was I could say how many it was
limited and it was only like five and I
was one of the FES was it a Jersey no it
was it was a package oh you got a
package it was
huh tourn oh the in tournament thing is
is
it listen
your new your new album is out yes
Dennis's daughter um everyone should go
support it are you going to be uh
hitting the road anytime soon of course
I'm trying to go on tour for sure Den
his daughter got to promote Dennis
daughter project that's the only way
it's going to move did your mom
obviously your your dad passed away but
is your mom like hey the next album my
name yo listen I'm telling you this
right now my mom's was like listen
Dennis you doing too much bro you doing
a little bit too much what's your mom's
name Tisha so album Number Two tisha's
daughter tisha's daughter I'm not gonna
tell or the deluxe the Delux how you
know yo listen all right cool you look
at me look at that Kev Kev done the
deluxe the deluxe is coming T's Edition
there's a situation where I'm feeling
like a deluxe should be put out I can't
tell you when but a deluxe should be put
out Deluxe on the way she says I did not
say that she all all but said it I'll
tell you that much isn't a good idea
it's a good chance it could be happening
for sure is it cold in New York in
December no it's not okay well you live
so you're used to it it's [__]
freezing anyway appreciate you coming
through thank you for having me Kev I
appreciate it Lola Brook boom fire uh
and then we'll we'll do a quick like
like a little two or three minute we'll
talk about the album and then yeah right
here we go yo it's the bootle C show man
uh look we got this young lady her new
album is out right now she's taking over
the show Dennis daughter Brook is in the
building uh uh how you feeling I'm
feeling good um just dropped Dennis's
daughter feeling excited I got some
closure now it's time to celebrate at
the same time work this project uh yeah
look the album uh is fire uh shout out
to your team I mean I know you've been
working on this album for a
while this particular
project close to a year about a year
okay well this your first album first
ever so so for you uh talk about like
obviously you got some big features on
here what was it like working with Bry
and Tiller like where were you at when
you first got his vocals
back I was in Florida nice yeah and I
remember it was just like weird type of
Vibes and they like everybody looking
like they just they being sneaky then
they like look listen to this so I'm
listening I'm like okay yeah then his
vocals came in I
said this is is real and like we could
put this out like I was excited so shout
outs to Florida Miami Florida cuz that's
when the first time I've heard uh Bryson
on you um talk about right now I feel
like we're like in the I always say like
the uh I would say like in 2017 18 the
New Renaissance of female rappers kind
of kicked off but now it just feels like
you guys Run rap so like referring to
someone as a female rapper kind of out
the door because y' kind of like Run rap
music now um who are some of your peers
that you just like you know obviously
you've worked with a lot of dope female
artists but like like Lotto city girls
go crazy I love sexy sexy red is amazing
sexy red is amazing she's out here on
tour pregnant running it up running it
up pregnant and working like the the I'm
sorry no guy can say they outworking
sexy red that girl is pregnant right now
and she has no shoes on most of the time
music videos whatever so God bless her
and her health because she trying to
make a way for her and her family for
sure uh your album uh talk about just
like if if anybody's listening on the
radio right now and they find you on
Spotify what uh song are they going to
first what what type of vibe we in let's
say we we had a party we had a party we
going to um make a pit stop at the pit
stop with Lola Brook in French Montana
oh shout out to French shout out to H
shout out to French Montana New York go
all right so look the album's out let's
get I'm going to let you introduce your
new single which has Bryson on it it's
going crazy let's get into it uh uh you
already know the Vibes it's your girl
Lola Brook and this is my new single You
featuring Bryon teller hey y bootleg Kev
what up with it let's get it fire